hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well book
eight
of saint augustine's confessions
contains
a very vivid description
of one of the phenomena in in moral
theory that we come to call across here
or weakness
or inconstancy of will
where a person knows what the right
thing to do
is but finds themselves even though they
want to do the right thing
even though they are drawn to it doing
the wrong thing
in part because they are also
drawn they have desires for
the wrong thing so the question is
how does this actually occur is this
something
easily explicable is this something we
can wrap our heads around or is this as
augustine suggests something monstrous
and the reason he talks about being
monstrous
in this case is he is in a garden he has
been
undergoing this long long process of
trying to
change who he is to enter into a full
relationship with with god
and to to leave behind
the excesses of his
his past the intemperance all of the
problems that he's been
going through
he's the he's the guy who's famous for
having said lord give me
chastity or continence but not yet
um and he's this is the reason why
because he's finding himself still
drawn to the things of the flesh it
actually
for augustine it's not just you know
food or wine or things like that it's
actually sexual desire
um so augustine knows what he
ought to be desiring and he wishes that
he
did in fact desire it more because he
does in fact desire it
namely to to change his life to become a
christian
to embrace god and at the same time he
still finds himself
drawn by these worldly earthly
carnal pleasures so he talks about
feeling as if he's being torn into and
this is something
i think many of us can relate to about
many different things
now augustine is going to walk
through this this incident and explore
what was going on in terms of
some mistaken ways of looking at this
he's contrasting it
specifically against this this sect that
he used to belong to the manichaeans
but their their doctrine could be taken
as sort of emblematic
you can get rid of the the religious
imagery of it
it can be emblematic of a lot of other
ways of looking at this
and then he proposes his own way of
making sense of this
so what is the mistaken point of view
he says the manichaeans would account
for this sort of thing by
saying well you actually have two
different wills
you have a good will inside you and you
have a bad will
and they kind of fight with each other
they compete
one is drawn to good things one is drawn
to bad
things and augustine says well
there's some problems with that
one of the big problems is going to be
that the will is actually something
unified that's why it has the
capacity for self-determination that it
that it has
that's something that's intrinsic to the
will but let's put that aside for a
moment
he says there's another problem with
this
not every case where i'm torn between
two alternatives
and i find myself unable to to
definitively
endorse or choose or pursue one of them
without also being drawn towards the
other one and sometimes i can find
myself in a sort of state of suspense
not every case is so simple as having a
good will
versus a bad will there could be cases
where i have
two different impulses
one drawing me to kill this guy over
here for no reason whatsoever or just
because they don't want something that
he's got
and the other over here wanting me
to not kill that guy over there so that
i can go
you know seduce this woman over here
which is also a bad act or steal
something or lie to somebody or
or pick whatever you want you know spray
graffiti on
on somebody's wall to face their
property um
so i i'm being torn in two different
directions but by two different bad
impulses we could have a similar case
with
goodwill i would love to contribute to
this charity over here
but i also need to use the money for the
operation
for my my ailing mother over here right
oh they're both such good things that
i'm being torn or
i really want to spend my time over
there
you know learning about wonderful things
but i also need to spend time over here
doing good works well
see it's not going to be
so simple as we just have a good will
and a bad will in those sorts of cases
how are you going to make sense of that
augustine complicates it even further
saying
we don't always just have two different
things that were torn towards
or drawn by we could have three or four
or
five who knows so this manichaean
moral psychology of saying well you just
have a good
good will and a bad will you know some
people you have a good wolf inside you
and a bad wolf inside you which which
gets stronger depends on which one you
feed
well what decides what's getting fat
this is one of the big problems this
sort of viewpoint
is really not going to be adequate
in part because we just saw it can't
adequately take account of the
difference between
you know a range of good objects or a
range of bad objects
it also can't address the fact how many
different impulses could there be basic
impulses
but it also lacks
the unity of the will that's required in
order to make sense
out of something like the capacity for
self-determination and therefore
moral responsibility
augustine says no it's actually more
like this
the person has one will
and you can actually choose
what to will for your will
that's also willing the will is
reflexive it can work on itself
and the will finds itself torn
by two different
desirable at least for for that will two
different things
one you know the good thing in this case
god
which reason and knowledge and eternal
law tells augustine you ought to be
pursuing this this is where you ought to
be
committing your life notice that's not
just about a single decision
it's about a course of action to
persevere in
but at the same time as he says you know
custom and habit and
you know even the personified uh
pleasures of the
flesh say you really want to leave us
behind
think about how much enjoyment you get
from us
you're you're going to be passing us up
forever
and so because he doesn't decide
all the way he's not able to persevere
in just going after the higher good
the thing that's actually a good thing
uh by the way carnal pleasures are not
in themselves a bad thing for for
augustine it's a bad thing
in this this particular respect weight
off against a good thing because you
should be pursuing the higher good
um in any case he says
i'm i'm not actually pursuing this
and you know i've got this divided line
drawn here
this is where the self-determining
faculty of the will comes in
the more that we give in to this stuff
the more that we sort of divide the will
up against itself and give precedence
to what's going after the lower good
the more that we
exercise some sort of discipline
or seek out the resources that are
needed
in order for us to break bad habits
to get away from old customs to
disengage the power
of you know old memories and all the
fun stuff that went with them the more
we can make our will something that
is going to go go this way go for the
higher thing
the goal of course is to ultimately
have one integrated
will
but that's often not completely possible
within
the lives that we're living augustine
would say so sometimes we actually
have to be you know just trying to
keep this part in check
and we do have that capacity
to a certain extent
notice that what we have done with the
will
in the past plays a role
for augustine and how much capacity we
actually do
have to modify
what we're directing our will towards
but
this is a very common experience of
lack of self-control of you know what's
often translated
as incontinence or in constancy of
will of not willing something all the
way through
you start a diet which you know is going
to be good for you
but you remember how good things taste
and you make it halfway through the day
dieting and then you know the other part
of your will
says man i really like those cookies
can i just have a cookie and and you
know
you tell yourself well if i have one
cookie i'm probably not just gonna have
one cookie i better not do that
but at a certain point because you don't
choose to persevere you do choose
to have the cookie and then you have the
other cookie and the next cookie and
then pretty soon you know the whole box
of cookies
we could come up with a lot of different
examples of this
this doesn't just concern cookies and
particular incidents this concerns
how a person chooses um
not only in individual situations but
over the course of their life where
are you actually going with the kind of
person that you want to be with the sort
of relationships that you want to have
with what it is that you actually want
to place
at the apex of what's valuable to you
and what it is that you're saying well
i might have to forego those things or
sacrifice those other good things
for this this higher good all of that
is what's going on in this discussion
and by the way
augustine understands how tough this can
be
he's able to make sense of this and yet
at the same time he's not able to
overcome it entirely
takes divine aid actually on his part
in his case to see him all the way
through he breaks down in tears
his companion is sitting next to him and
sees him all shaken up
and it's only because of some sort of
you know
help from from the higher good
that augustine himself is able to get
himself through this
so he's very conscious of just
how hard changing the
the vectors the direction of of the
established will
can actually be and how difficult it can
be to bring ourselves to have a
really integrated will that's not
bifurcated that's not
split but where you know what we can
draw from this is we don't want to
we don't want to use the kind of faculty
notion that the manikins we're having
where we just have
we have good parts and bad parts and
it's just a matter of you know
which one is going to win because which
one's going to win
is partly up to us that's because the
good parts and bad parts are actually
mixed
together in the will